it's November 1996 and tonight your
parents are letting you have a sleepover
Space Jam is currently in theaters
Eminem has emerged with his very first
album and the last episode of the
original Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
has aired on CBS it's Friday night your
best friend is coming over after school
and the balls in your court
[Music]
[Music]
it wasn't a sleepover without video
games so who better for this series and
then the guy who made Mario Mario
Charles Martin a little mummy the story
goes like this
but I actually crashed the audition I I
just walked in the door uninvited and I
thought to myself
Italian plumber from Brooklyn hey get
out of my face I'm working here another
sudden I hear action I go you know I'm a
Mario let's make a pizza pie together
and the rest is history
Pizza time what is considering pizza
from the 90s one snack instantly comes
to mind we've caught Justin convenience
he works on the marketing team for
Totino's pizza rolls the rules were
invented by a man named Gino Poochie use
a bit more of a maverick yes you had his
fingerprint and lots of different
businesses he ran a frozen Chinese food
company called Chongqing
they sold everything from chop suey to
chow mein and even egg balls see what he
did there you think of the DNA and what
it looks like it's essentially an Agora
hole with heaps of filling in the inside
and once you convince people what it was
and then they actually went out tried it
neighborhood millions of pizza rolls
eaten per day hooked it all added up or
30 million per day pretty amazing
makes sense I mean a serving is what
like 15 I believe a carbon-fibre no it
can't be
the ultimate match it only takes three
words to set the next scene the wetter
is this is Lonnie Johnson NASA
scientists an inventor of the supers
and nerf gun during the day he worked on
the highly classified stealth bomber
program and at night he worked on the
super soaker I told my daughter I'm
gonna be your warrior you know I used
some very fundamentally engineering
principles to design it so that it would
work really well it's dude a lot of
water I find it curious sometimes that
you know people seem to make a big fuss
about me and the super soaker ahem I'm
still trying to get used to that
over 1 billion dollars in sales a
hundred and seventy five different
variations and an induction into the toy
Hall of Fame we get it and there it is
you're winning sleepover and some of the
people who helped make it in 1996
[Music]